today we're going to be speaking with
professor michael gambon who teaches
history at kutztown university of
pennsylvania specializing in modern
america also is author of the
forthcoming book modern conspiracies in
america separating fact from fiction
it's out in less than two weeks really
great to have you on i appreciate your
time
thank you for having me i really this is
a great opportunity i appreciate it yeah
so this this is such an important topic
right now in the united states of
america kind of in the era of
covet vaccines trumpism flat earth the
2020 election we could kind of go on and
on and on we've talked
quite a bit about general techniques and
strategies to talk to people
about beliefs that may not be based in
fact but i think we can all kind of feel
that there's a difference between the
belief that
tax cuts for the rich are good for the
economy kind of in one bucket and on the
other side the belief that i don't know
there uh is a secret plot to create the
covet pandemic in order to create an
opportunity to vaccinate people which
will then allow mind control and you
know on and on and on we can feel that
there's sort of some difference between
those two things can you first talk a
little bit about the difference between
beliefs that might just be wrong and
what we would characterize as a
conspiracy theory
yeah i think i mean when i started
teaching this class i really wanted it
to be a research class i mean how do you
figure out how to apply a basic template
for logic
what i always tell the students i said
you have a claim it has to be matched
with a proof it has to be
and then we can talk about degrees of
evidence so
we just finished up sandy hook and q
anon in my class and
one of the tells that you have is if you
have somebody making a claim simply
followed by more claims
uh with no proof in the you know
following in the wake of that then
that's a that's a huge flag
so and that's what you tend to always
want i tell them tune your ear to that
you know when you hear this kind of
hopscotching gish gallop
moving along the surface type of
approach if it has no depth then that's
a problem so
we can talk about tax cuts and economics
fine
but if you're going to claim that a
microchip was in the uh you know coveted
vaccination show me the proof
and
the other way i look at it if you have
the big claims the giant global
conspiracies big claim requires big
proof it's the same
you know basically the same idea but
it's just a bigger threshold
is there a shortcut not to changing
people's minds we'll get later to the
changing of minds but to being able to
ascertain whether you're speaking to
someone who's open to revising their
views i think so i think
you start you know
i think one of the things i said the
book is you apply the 80 20 rule i mean
you should be starting off by listening
more than talking
and i think that's a skill unfortunately
we're losing in civil discourse and
that's something i'm trying to teach in
class you know to sit back and listen
because teachers are the worst at this
we we're talkers we have captive
audiences so
first thing listen see where they're
coming from
one of the key things you need to know
is the context i mean what are you know
where are they where do they live
um and so on you're basically trying to
build a
a profile of the person you're talking
to and just and simply you don't want to
go right to a quick conclusion and
dismiss them
so that's what you're always doing in
any conversation
there's the other
kind of side to this
and i hesitate to ever say there's
another side to things when we're really
talking about kind of one-sided
circumstances but sometimes you will
hear the claim from some who assert
conspiratorial beliefs
that what you just accept everything
everybody tells you you always accept
the official story you accept what the
government says i mean medicine has been
wrong science has been wrong governments
have lied etc what's the best way to
kind of handle that idea and approach
that
yeah i think i tell them and i have a
lot of criminal justice majors but i
think in general treat this like you
would if you're on a jury
so you have a burden of proof but one
thing you're never going to have is 100
certainty so you have to reach that
level to say is it 51 enough do i need
more
um so that's how you're measuring this
um and also we were just talking about
this uh this week um evidence evolves
um you have examples where you know in
in some of these you know conspiracies
you're gonna have revelations that might
take decades
or technology will change and you'll
have better ways to analyze something
so
patience is also a virtue for both of
those things and that's again you're
trying to teach americans patience
that's an ongoing enterprise
do you address the idea of sometimes
one might assert a certain belief not
because they actually believe it but
because it signals that they're part of
a team and i'll give an example of that
you know after the 2020 election there
was polling done about do you believe
trump won
and the numbers among republicans at the
time were quite high i think in the
immediate aftermath it was like 57 and
that number has waned over time but
within that 57 percent
presumably there were some what we might
call true believers who literally
believe trump actually won but then
there are others for whom claiming it
signals support for trump or or
identifies them with the team for lack
of a better term
where does that figure in to the studies
and the work that you do
i think i've used a lot of polling and a
lot of analysis of polling especially by
an author named berensky
you have you know influencers i mean
that's a new term but you've always had
people who lead opinions because they
they're trusted they have agency they're
public officials
um so people tend to rely on that and
they they can guide that or they can
abuse it i think joe mccarthy is a
classic example
um
but one of the things that came up in
queuing on you know of all the reading i
did uh wired magazine had a great story
on you know how q and i is like an
alternate reality game
so what you have is you have a universe
you're
basically it's world building so you've
got certainty
and rewards so within that group um you
have that recognition
and i think what that lends people in
very uncertain times and this is very
historical i mean you could have said
this in 1919 or today
it gives people an anchor to hang on to
in a very you know difficult fearful
uncertain time
so whether i'm a leader or a follower i
mean there are uses for these things
that
you know can be manipulated
yeah that you touched on something which
we've we've talked about before which is
if you take something like sandy hook as
an example or 9 11 maybe you're good
examples of this
sometimes it seems like one of the
primary motivating factors in getting
people to choose
one of these assertions rather than what
we might call the official empirically
based version of the story
is that the randomness with which bad
things happen in the world is
extraordinarily unsettling and so for
some folks it's almost more pacifying to
believe
it wasn't a random thing that could have
happened at any time it was planned it
was deliberate and and there's more
certainty in the world is that an
important psychologically motivating
factor for more than just a few of these
absolutely um i use a book by rob
brotherton called suspicious minds and
he talks about the messy desk
test where people instinctively want to
impose order on something that's simple
but that applies to a lot of things in
life
so rather than be overwhelmed you can
you make this construct and
it works toward intellectual values but
also you know you could say uh instinct
um what you might see is common sense
so one of the things we suspect is
always threats and we tend to associate
these threats with the other and it
could you know usually you know the
brand new immigrant i mean that's a
classic nativist go-to
and a lot of these conspiracies uh you
saw that in 16 with you know the three
million boats
um it's a constant drum beat even during
covid
um who's bringing covet well the these
other people them
that's why when i first started the
class i looked at the protocols of the
elders of zion and it's amazing how that
keeps coming back in different forms but
it's basically the same thing
that's about as old a story as it gets
but i saw updates to this this year it's
amazing yeah let's talk a little bit
about anti-semitism i uh as a jewish
person myself you know i've been aware
of anti-semitism for as long as i can
remember being aware of of anything
and a lot of the modern conspiracy
theories sometimes much more subtly than
others go back to or have their roots in
an anti-semitic idea you know the idea
of
the other bringing disease that's a
classic anti-semitic idea from you know
800 900 years ago at least
globalist now often used as a sort of uh
catch-all for
wealthy jewish men right when we talk
about they talk about soros they talk
about klaus schwab is a big big one here
um can you talk a little bit about
where the origins of so many of these
things stemmed from anti-semitism and
whether even some of the conspiracy
theorists realize that
i i don't think they do although it's
been constantly pointed out
so for q anon you have you know the
endless stories about blood drinking and
child trafficking and i the first thing
i automatically think of is the blood
libel which goes back for centuries
so i think at the root of a lot of these
conspiracies and i think richard
hofstadter pointed this out really well
you've got a moral judgment that you're
making you're posing a moral threat not
just a political or social or an
economic one so you've got this group of
identified outcasts that you're posing
as a threat to the social order
and you can go very viscerally you know
in the case of q and on with the
children
so that's a very consistent theme
threats to children whether it's the
middle ages or right now
and we can always associate that with
this you know labeled outcast group
it keeps reoccurring because it works um
it's it's odd to see
anyone's going to argue against
protecting children i mean it's very
altruistic but it can be very easily
distorted and it is i saw this during
the supreme court
nomination um what do you make of flat
earth
surging
at a time when we have the most advanced
technology we've ever had
and the most sort of empirical means of
ascertaining the real shape of a planet
well we do we do chemtrails in class so
it's kind of in the same ballpark
one of the common themes i see in all
these conspiracies is there are always
complexities
i don't know too many people who know
structural engineering enough to talk
about 911 or
epidemiology since 2020. so
i think in all these things what you
have is like flat earth is a way to
simplify
and take back an idea that experts
control
and in the meantime what you're doing is
making enormous numbers of mistakes
but you have certainty and you don't
care about the complexity uh you're just
basically bypassing it
i love talking about chemtrails and flat
earth because my science majors lose
their minds when they look at some of
the basic mistakes
um but that goes back to you know
you know things you can look up and
assert
um back to the education system and you
know competing with the ability to
oversimplify that's that's that's kind
of the tug of war you have going on with
that
so now let's talk about changing minds
uh we've had many different
conversations with experts about how do
you change minds you know the
low-hanging fruit is beating people over
the head with facts is rarely effective
uh showing empathy listening a lot as
you point out is effective but still
we've not really found any significant
shortcut i mean oftentimes you're
talking about building a relationship
with someone not even over a period of
hours but often over days weeks months
or whatever the case may be
where
what is your sense of the most effective
techniques to change minds
you know it's well i'm an educator
obviously i've been doing this for a
long time and
one of the devices i had set up was
having
you know
a group of students assertive conspiracy
and a group of students debunked a
conspiracy and we're training them in
basic logic
facts but also in civil discourse
so in combination that's where i have
some hope because that's the thing you
don't have really online you have
you know threads where the insults break
out in seconds and
it that's not the way that should work i
mean the face-to-face version of this is
the better way because
you know outside the internet that's the
way people used to debate and you can
look somebody in the eye
i think it's a very hard thing to do i
think one of the things that struck me
about the recent past um
shows with a sense of humor who don't
take themselves too seriously
um well are very effective that's what
jon stewart proved years ago um john
oliver does that still i mean
you can you can say this stuff with a
smile on your face and not the dark
implications of disagreement so part of
its method part of its structure
um i'm going to keep working away at it
as long as i'm teaching which is going
to be for more years than now so we'll
see
when it comes to like assessing the
i i i'm going to use the word danger but
maybe it's not actually the right word
but when it comes to assessing the
danger of widespread belief of a
particular conspiracy theory i think
many of us can understand how at least
in a direct sense there are some
conspiracy theories like for example the
comet ping pong thing that led to an
actual shooting whereas for many of us
we say flat earth it's comparatively
more benign some experts we've
interviewed say
that's true and yet
it's rare that someone believes only one
of these things and flat earth links to
something else and it links to
anti-semitism and all these different
things so k
we're let's try to put together sort of
a theory of this we can understand the
differences between the immediate
impacts of some of these conspiracy
theories but how do we evaluate them on
some kind of spectrum
i think one of the things i noticed with
q anon was that it was early on
dismissed as lone actors on the fringe
and i think what
obviously january 6 proved a lot of that
wrong um the same systems where these
beliefs can overlap and combine
you know with whatever you know media
platform you have they're also the same
places that these threats can organize
themselves
and that's a huge concern
because you can't really shut down
social media it's like playing
electronic whack-a-mole um you can ban
somebody from a platform they'll just
move to another one
so i i'm really concerned after night
i'm sorry after january 6th when it
comes to coordinating
acting
people will move on their convictions
and like you mentioned in the polling
these aren't small numbers of people
even if you take the tiniest percentage
you still have a lot of people willing
to act on what they're doing and that
really concerns me because there's you
know the treatment of this is almost
like a crusade
um
so in my own classroom or you know i'm
gonna i actually have an election worker
i'll be at the polls in a two weeks
i'm constantly worried about somebody
showing up you know to try to make sure
that the election's not stolen
i've been asked that question dozens of
times in two years
so i do have concerns
let's talk a little bit about social
media
in the book technopoly neil postman
wrote that there's a sort of uh
naivete in thinking that with any
platform or technology
you can eliminate any of the bad uses of
it and only be left with the sort of
good and i'm oversimplifying but the
idea that a platform a technology comes
with good and bad and the question is
finding a balance of sort of regulation
and education
that will maximize the good and minimize
the bad we can think about lots of great
things about social media and also it
has made the spread of conspiracy
theories and false beliefs rampant like
wildfire
what should be
a regulatory framework for some of these
platforms
that's a big that's a big question um
so best example i have online is a
website called metabunk which has
moderated conversations
um they do have standards and it it
works
um but how far that could be extended
and spread you know throughout the
entire
internet that's you know that's that's
the problem um
and i think you pointed out i mean where
these things might appear in places you
would have never suspected
uh the natural parenting community in
cuban i mean no one saw that
although you could see the elements
after the fact so
it's a it's a very hard thing to talk
about because the more you crank down on
free speech the more that you're going
to have the reaction and
i think it becomes self-defeating after
a point um
i'm back to trying to you know the
education part before they log on i mean
that's that's what i'm looking at that
that's i mean for me the greatest
immunizer to people falling for this
stuff is
you start teaching critical thinking and
media literacy
probably at age 11 or something like
that right
well and judging by the this course has
changed since i started you know back in
2016. i had 25 students right now i have
145. wow so i this thing get it it fills
in within a couple days every time i run
it and i run multiple sections now so
it might be like a factory for reason
and rational thinking i hope right
that's the dream and the book is
forthcoming in uh uh less than two weeks
it's modern conspiracies in america
separating
fact from
fiction i've pre-ordered it on amazon
already i encourage the audience to do
the same we've been speaking with the
book's author professor michael gambon
really appreciate your time today and
this was a treat i got to tell you thank
you